so here's what's happening
governor newsom passed a law that says
hey
in a recall the recall candidate can put
his party preference on the ballot so
that way instead of it saying
should gavin newsom be recalled it says
should gavin newsom
a democrat be recalled it's marketing
it's marketing 101 in a democratic state
it is very brilliant that law they
passed but guess what
in the law he signed he said you have to
make that determination at the beginning
of the recall which was february of 2020
this particular recall
he failed to do that missed his own
deadline
is now suing his own administration
calling it
unfair unconstitutional and unreasonable
you know what's unfair
unconstitutional and unreasonable the
facts that you still wear in california
the fact that he can raise unlimited
amounts of money from anyone
and i can raise 32 400 per person recall
candidates
have campaign contribution limits
governor newsom does not
and yet he's saying in his own lawsuit
that his own law that he signed in the
law is unconstitutional
because other candidates can pick their
party preference later when people would
give me flack about voting libertarian
you're throwing your vote away you're
throwing your vote away that five
percent barrier is everything
if you can get to five percent of the
national vote it unlocks an entire
different level
of uh funding that you have access to
and ballot access
you have to get five percent of the
national vote in order to
access this the funding equality and the
unpack that
yeah so unpack it so basically right
like if anybody ever actually really
cared to this is why ross perot was so
important when he got 18
of the vote he he essentially he walked
clinton into office he stole
18 of bush's vote right this is
he he did he walked him in so what he
was able to do then is he had
financial and ballot access the next
time that's why they begged him to run
again he was four years older he didn't
care he just didn't want bush he hated
bush he hated what the bushes stand for
he actually never really wanted to be
president he wanted to use it for his
personal brand he wanted to get his
point across and he did that
and remember the the the three-hour late
night uh
uh case studies with the biz doc that uh
that ross perot used to do every night
and this is why we need to get off oral
you know what i'm saying
he was talking about getting off our oil
dependence before you know this was 25
years ago yeah
so you know we the only way to stabilize
the middle east if we get off oral
yeah and that's that was this close to
being president united states so the
the idea is if you can get five percent
of the national vote
if you get five percent you have ballot
access equality
so you have to be on the ballot for the
next election cycle in every state
as opposed to having to petition for
ballot access and also the way the media
works
is you have uh equal opportunity laws so
like if somebody gives a democratic
candidate
x amount of air time they have to you
should know this tom
by law give the republican candidate the
same amount of air time
if they request it if you get five
percent of the ballot access now the
libertarian candidate
whoever it was can ask for that same
amount of equal air time
so they can't have a debate and not
allow gary johnson on the stage they
can't have a debate and not allow justin
amish on stage
that five percent is everything so with
gary johnson in 2016 they got like 1.8
percent
and then with uh this clown show that
they just had with joe jorgensen and
spike cohen
it went down like 0.9 so they were
they're going in the wrong direction but
five percent is everything that five
percent
gives you a puncher's chance four years
from that five percent
suing over a law that you voted in or
that you signed
is unbelievable any other politician
does that they're getting destroyed
well i then that's exactly why i think
we and we have a legal team working on
it we uh we want to sue
and make that extremely clear that's
expensive to sue
it's probably going to cost a hundred
thousand dollars to get a temporary
restraining order which you can get out
as early as next week
and july 4th weekend which slows things
down which is probably why newsome filed
his lawsuit when he did
right before july 4th weekend uh but
it's it's all to uh to to bury his own
mistakes
his own hypocrisy of his own policies
uh in in in other news and i mean look
marketing wise i get it but it's it's a
scam
you know here's a big question in
california is there a silent
majority out there that has to support
gavin newsom because he's a democrat and
you got to put the sign on in your front
yard because
you are under so much pressure to have
those political beliefs if you live in
california
you literally cannot admit that you're a
republican it's career suicide
could these people be stepping up and
going and actually getting him out
i hope so and and that's why that's why
i'm running is i believe
that this is not a republican recall
it's a california recall and
californians need a new better option
and that's me by the way the numbers are
you know
out of the recall votes i think it's 79
or 80 as republicans but 20 are
democrats so it's not like it's just
republicans calling out you know how
he'll always say this is a republican
it's not it's actually not it's people
on both sides that are not happy about
it
and he's spinning that totally that's
all he's branding it as is a right-wing
nut job like q anon is going after him
or something
speaking of nut jobs do you think there
are people that are gonna look at you
sitting at a table with four men in
close proximity with no mask on and say
this guy can't lead us
we don't have to wear masks anymore uh
anywhere from california
even though delta variance is a delta
variant
uh yeah yeah on the 15th uh that those
requirements went away so you can
actually oh that's nice
yeah on the 15th
came out just a couple days ago saying
you have to wear masks then you got
everybody worn masks again
she suggested that we were always
wearing messages in interviews
yeah on zoom meetings
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye